auf 1378 kilometer australien mit
singapore airlines täglich im airbus
a380 ab zürich
alice springs in ihr es vor der passage
14 shop können wir mit ihnen fahren und
ein wenig film ok
die latte
ok
ich pcs mal in australien ist es wird
heiß aber gerade so heiß mit dem annik
rechnet uns bekannt alice springs ist
viel schlimmer als das mini reichs
startet im zentrum für australien das
heißt mitte im harz vom roten kontinent
[Musik]
nun ich bin eher so wie der baxi vor der
heimreise profit im dorf
internationale studie sagen aber dass
türken vor australien die glückliche
wahl sind ich komme es vor schmid
vorstelle und darum will ich die manche
keine leere läuft und ich gehe zum
beispiel und wer sie die glücklichsten
zur wahl
[Musik]
bis vor sechs gebärden riesig das zeigen
die dimensionen von 112 300 kilometer in
sebes gedanken zusammen bei mir einen
traum radreise forscht unter ganz
kontinent vor der wir stehen uns mehr
von zahl platz und großstadt über
autobahnen und natur straße auf dem
wasser und abwasser
[Musik]
blass
es folgten drei siege holen
als ich verstehen
links
wenn ich meine familie und freunde von
mir erzählt hat und meister anders
reagiert australien das doch da was nur
gerade so wie vor giftige die systeme
von sandy geboren gibt dir als antithese
vom glück
im internet alle tracks neindorf
gefunden der schlange vor alice springs
diese reptilien im ganzen land
ja uns schon schlange gefangen heute
morgen nein ich habe die kinder in die
krippe gebracht bevor mir extra
tiefschlag offizielle messer wahllos ein
notruf wenn der ex und praxis werde von
der stadt zahlt die reptilien spezialist
jetzt auf die füße kino oder in alice
springs und sagt diese giftschlangen in
der stopp schauen was es ist mit der
plastikbox hand war es schlauer firma
wo muss ich stehen fest egal wo ich muss
zuerst schauen was es ist
das ist gar keine schlangen sondern eine
blindschleiche wir nennen sie ein los
eidechsen die sind sehr verbreitet hier
in einem springs das ist eine eidechse
ist erkennt man an den uhren
das unterscheidet eidechsen von
schlangen hat in jeder so eine
vorrichtung zu hause
nein das gehört irgendwie zur ausrüstung
der bauarbeiter die sie gefangen haben
die blindschleiche dass ich außerhalb
der stadt wieder frei jetzt zeigt mir
direkt schießt center
da haben wir also nur eine kleine
gefangen ja das kommt vor
mal hast du als kleines mal eine große
schlager aber unsere westen bremsweg zum
beispiel wird nur etwa so groß wenn du
eine fang aus die etwa so ist die kann
ich umbringen wirklich eine kleine
schlange in alice springs kann tödlich
sein
du musst dich sehr vorsichtig sein die
vorhin war harmlos die zwei zeigen die
ich gestern gefangen hat
die zwei hier habe ich in der stadt
gefangen ersten zwei western browns netz
ein einfaches erkennungsmerkmal siehst
du die punkte wenn du flecken aber auch
siehst ist es eine western großen sees
nervös das ist weil ich sie frisch
gefangen habe sie versucht immer sich zu
verstecken
sie will grundsätzlich immer für uns
flüchten
aber wenn jemand in panik gerät und
versucht so eine schlange mit einer
schaufel oder so zu töten
dann kann sie extrem schnellangriff und
ihr gift ist brutal stark bis von so
einer schlange kann dein körper innert
kürzester zeit schwer schädigen
bekannten weniger als einer halben
stunde das bewusstsein verlieren
diese schlange kann wirklich gefährlich
seien
zwei cent an
[Musik]
woher denn eigentlich keine begeisterung
für reptilien
ich wuchs auf dem land auf im süden von
australien
meine mutter hatte eine tierhaarallergie
hund oder katze konnte mich also nie in
frage
darum brachte ich irgendwann eidechsen
nach hause hast du familie
ja ich habe eine partnerin und zwei
kinder
1 und 3 jahre wie gehen sie damit um
dass du so einen gefährlichen job hast
meine ältere tochter realisiert bereits
was ich machen sie sie zu hause immer
die säcke mit den schlangen und weiß
dass sie nicht in die medien
zum abschied seit mehr 30 bürger von gif
turkey youngster gesunde portion respekt
lang
denn wer mit angst reise findet glück
mit sich
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen vor user stoppt
ohne wachstum ersteindruck vor der krise
vor dem kontinent die unglaublich
wichtig das gefühl der grenzenlosigkeit
die stars der schlüssel zum blick
bitte mehr jemand kennt einige der
besten stoffe verwalter teil campbell
und schafft im outback in der wildnis
mit die vor australien
aber guten morgen ich suche day campbell
freue mich ich bin vom schweizer
fernsehen
schön dich zu treffen du zeigst mir also
heute dein revier-elf schnitt arbeit
ließ league und wirkt unsicher
trotzdem spiel erschienen stolz dass a
machine head back to revive australien
und ich darf ihnen heute kommen in
normaler arbeitstag begleitet
[Musik]
laut bag im schnitt nur dort von der
schmitt besitzer vor dem land das land
vorsieht hunderte vorjahres in dem stamm
der sogenannte krieg als ranger auf
schienen eigenen land schaffe jobs und
riera um machen stolz und glücklich
[Musik]
das ist also das land eine familie
ja das ist mein land meine familie meine
onkel und tanten und meine großeltern
leben hier die häuser da drüben gehören
meinen tanten junge wuchs ich hier
draußen auf aus dieser erfahrung heraus
kann auch mein wunsch schwanger zu
werden
diese hügel rauf und runter zu krabbeln
das hat mich geprägt als ich älter wurde
habe ich erkannt wie wichtig dieses land
für unser britschen es ist heutzutage
leben die aborigines doch meist in den
steckern und du willst raus aus der
stadt
danach den ersten jahren hier draußen
verbrachte ich fast mein ganzes leben in
der stadt
jetzt will ich wieder hier raus in die
landschaft meiner kindheit
das ist meine lebensaufgabe dieser
landschaft sorge zu tragen
dafür sind wir ja da nachdem ich meine
mutter verloren hatte
du hast deine mutter verloren ja vor
sechs oder sieben jahren
sie starb an krebs mir wurde klar dass
ich mein leben jetzt in die hand nehmen
muss und einen guten beruf brauche um
für meine familie sorgen zu können
jetzt habe ich wohl einen der besten
berufe dieses kind
[Musik]
the day ist verheiratet und hat zwei
kinder
im moment lebt er mit seiner familie in
alice springs china wunsch war dass
schiene sind gleich wie hier in der
natur gewachsen
[Musik]
es ist dies bildet zum ranger ist
ausspruchs folgt geprüft westen
australiens hoch sehen ist eine von
denen ganz wenige operation ist was es
geschafft hätte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
welche fliegen meinst du die die große
die hier versucht die tauchen meist nach
einem größeren regen wenn sie dich
stechen mit dem musst du hier in dieser
hitze leben ist das trinkwasser
ja das ist trinkwasser für die wandler
kann mir helfen mit dem schlauch wir
schieben ihnen hier unter das netz
im sommer steht thermometer auf bis zu
50 grad
die natürliche wasserquellen in
österreich tätige wassertanks
eingegangen waren rösler könnte
dort drüben auf dem hast siehst du sie
hinzu
sie haben mich wohl zu viele fliegen
gestochen
bist du sicher dass es die fliegen sind
glaube ich schon an einigen stellen
schmerz ist und im gesicht ich spüre
dass mein gesicht langsam an schwer weil
ich mehr schweizer als sonst zum glück
finden eine reiseapotheke als
antiallergikum so schlecht habe ich mich
in den 20 jahren hier draußen noch nie
gefühlt wenn du willst
ich kann selbst fallen
bist du sicher es ist nur dieser junge
ist so unangenehm ist aber ich kann sich
alleine zurückfahren und allein sich
zurück und ranger stations vorn
wenigstens
vielen dank für den tollen ausflug sei
vorsichtig auf dem heimweg war wirklich
schön mit dir und pass auf dich auf
gute fahrt
so blieb mir nichts anderes übrig war
michael einzig ruft er schnarcht im
outback vorbereitet
eigentlich wenn ihr erfolgskonto das in
der wildnis giftschlange mini
griechisches sorge haben sie war
ich habe jetzt von mir sammelstellen
ausstrahle die sind so aggressiv als
gestochen das ist grauenhaft und das hat
millionen abermillionen gefühl dass ich
das schwimmen wissen
[Musik]
die startflagge mache mir vorstelle
wenig und es ist immer noch übertragen
das könne vor der wahl ist panik
[Musik]
später habe ihm versichert dass er
geheime chancen machen seit er am
telefon
zerstreuung rechtsklick verkrampfen
einzige testspiel spielgefühl
[Musik]
ich bekomme hier ein erster eindruck und
faszination ausstrahlen ausmacht
die vita und das gefühl der
grenzenlosigkeit
[Musik]
dennoch ein schiff stach pflege
zurückzogen
die britische bbc auf anhieb will
[Musik]
meine erste große reise und noch vor dem
mittag eine schon 340 kilometer auf den
zahn
[Musik]
naja
da geht's zum 1
an bekannte heilige war vorzüglich
verbieten was mich interessiert sind
abwahl abschieds von der australischen
geschäfts auf meinem weg stoße aber
zwangsläufig sowie das klischee die die
stolze sentiments
australien ist es so riesig dass nicht
einmal alle über die dicken australien
dritte zone wir sind hier unmittelbar
namen stuart highway und hier verläuft
die zone durch so das heißt ich stehe
auf 47 hatte ich schon eine stunde
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin erwachsen legende the track
einmal die handelsroute war durch
endloses buschland vier tage verkehr
fahrzeug
es ist kein großer leidet
funk allergie
erst erstes känguru roadsign australia
weiteres tod im vorjahr sympathie oder
vier andere geworden sind
der autovermieter viele kängurus quandt
immer wieder grund zur gefährlichen
manöver und tragische unfall es geht es
ungeschriebenes gesetz
wer unterwegs ob es trotz die er trifft
müsse so krömer
[Musik]
mittlerweile eine über diese
kilometerzahl und langsam wird es dunkel
einzig seitlich weit und breit ist
william krieg als partner das modell
eine tankstelle und ein paar blatt hätte
die wundervoll 5
wer ist denn so berühmt dass ihr mit der
kamera grund sich etwa adriana von der
tankstelle hat für uns hier angerufen
und zimmer reserviert
[Musik]
mich hat sie nicht angerufen aber das
kriegen wir schon hin
und dir genießt das feierabendbier heute
nicht wirklich klar hatte ich angerufen
und zimmer reserviert nicht keine ahnung
wen sie angerufen hat aber sie sollte
zimmer für uns reservieren und auf
welchen namen weiß nicht die jungs aus
der schweiz
ich habe keine reservationen
aber ich habe freie zimmer für einen ja
nur eine nacht
[Musik]
william kritischen oder verreisen die
nach einer langen tag und erforscht
unerträgliches genesis holz beschäftigt
noch dazu um vor allem es
[Musik]
wieso wird
am anderen morgen noch bekanntschaft mit
dem zauberberg und sympathischer typ
lorig und unterhaltsam ihm kehrt nicht
nur das pop container motel one
übernachtete im chat donzdorf
[Musik]
ich bin der sekretär gemeinderat
feuerwehrkommandant und zuständig für
die stromversorgung und das wasser
angeht
ich mache alles vom chef bis zum
hilfsarbeiter über nötig helfe ich in
der küche und prozedur hotelzimmer man
muss wirklich vielseitig sein
ich sitze nicht einfach im büro hinter
meinem computer und habe nach acht
stunden feierabend sieben tage die woche
24 stunden im einsatz so dorf ist
wirklich glücklich finde wir können uns
sehr glücklich schätzen so viel platz
haben alle dieselbe sprache sprechen und
alle die gleichen chancen im leben hat
wir haben einen gemeinschaftssinn ins
helfen länder opec ist dieser
gemeinschaft sehen besonders ausgeprägt
nur wenn wir einander helfen können wir
hier draußen überleben genauso wie top
100 die futuristische hier verewigt
darunter import schweiz die chance
händlern
und was hat's gleich und seine flugzeug
einem besseren ort kannst du nicht
finden
das ist ja richtig werbung für schweizer
fernsehen
der treffer zeigte schiedsrichter auto
bin ohne klima laute stimme mittagshitze
von pro jahr als erstes das abläuft den
anderen menschen spottbillig diese
schlussendlich im besitz von ganze dorf
ich sage dir hier draußen zu leben prägt
den charakter
vereinfachter hoch in der wellblechhütte
da drüben steht unser generator der das
ganze dorf versorgt ich zeige dir wo ich
lebe
das ist das einzige stück rasen im
ganzen dorf und das ist mein schloss mit
swimmingpool
alleine hier draußen zu leben
du bist nie wirklich alleine geht los
ich bin ständig beschäftigt mit modellen
mithalten unterhaltsarbeiten im dorf du
hast ja viele leute mit denen du
plaudern kannst aber ein richtig
persönliches gespräch gibt es da doch
nicht nein weißt du hier draußen musst
du wirklich selbstständig leben kann
wenn du das nicht kannst hältst du es
nicht aus laut bag musste wirklich
halten nehmen sein
wenn nicht reibt sich die wildnis und
den wahnsinn die hitze die fliegen
beträgt
[Musik]
sogar historische museum hätte tremmel
spürte es sammelsurium für altmetall
rakete und flugzeugteilen man im outback
gefunden hat ganz in der nähe
als name lässt estland fragte der 58
jährige strotzt vor energie
mich nimmt wunder was ist die motivation
jeden morgen oft stau und schiff wieder
und arbeitswoche du meinst abgesehen von
den telefonanrufen beweg deinen arsch
aus dem bett und macht sich an die
arbeit
wenn ich morgens nicht aus dem bett
komme und motivierten tag bleibt alles
liegen
das ganze system würde innert kürzester
zeit zusammenbrechen
ich denke eine wichtige herausforderung
ist das bewusstsein wo wir uns hier
befinden
das ist eine motivation die mich
antreibt du siehst was du erreicht hast
was du für die kommenden generationen
geschaffen hast das ist mir wichtig du
kannst also gar nie pause machen das
wäre leicht
ich müsste nur den schlüssel drehen und
den generator streiten ob ich das will
oder nicht hängt davon ab wie streng der
letzte abend der papa geschäft ich bin
ja es geht uns doch alle gleich es gibt
die tage an dem du motiviert und es gibt
die tage an denen du alles etwas ruhiger
angehen muss das wichtigste du brauchst
ein ziel im leben revision wieder
verwirklichen kannst dann wirst du
belohnt
der travel betrieb zu allem dazu nur ein
flugblatt auf dem treffen die
jungfräulichen vorraber im parc bedient
er ist taylor shepard und erzählt mir
riesige chefpiloten vor dem lokal
airline d'italia noch business mit
touristen blick ins outback
[Musik]
ein pilot in einer rezession geschafft
damals war aber ziemlich vielseitig und
flexibel sie ja so ist es
du musst wirklich vielseitig sein du
musst eine gute mechanikerin sein muss
gut mit menschen umgehen können
es gibt viele touristen die hier
vorbeikommen an der rezeption genau du
kochst du auch ja klar das ist schon
okay so wir machen alle alles langweilig
wird es bestimmt d'italia verzählt mir
der frühere pilot schick sondern nur
zusammen sind eigentlich nur in den
sommerferien australien schied in ihrem
berufsalltag jörg den ferien weilen just
vor wald entdeckt hast du schon einmal
in der schweiz ja ich habe ein jahr lang
in der schweiz gelebt nein wirklich wo
ich bin in wohlen zur schule gegangen
und habe ein drei unterschiedlichen
orten gelebt in einem kleinen dorf
namens bett fiel in muri und den han
[Musik]
ich lebe in zug also in bar
da bin ich jeden tag mit dem motorrad
durch gefahren
hast du dort eine schule besucht ja ich
habe ein austauschjahr gemacht nachdem
ich die schule in australien
abgeschlossen hatte und ich habe in der
schweiz fußball gespielt
der frauenfußball ist in der schweiz auf
einem unglaublich hohen niveau
ich habe viel gelernt du hast fußball
gespielt ja wir wollen dann trägst du
sicher weiße socken wie alle akw nein
ich habe wieder auf schwarze socken
umgestellt wie später die teile macht
mehr das angebot wenn die welle fliege
chemie zu meinem nächsten sie ist kamera
team ist begeistert ich weniger
bist du startklar
[Musik]
die thalia meint der blick von oben das
ist australisch klick als kabinettschef
[Musik]
wir pflegen ein riesiges am 2
toni ist die playstation erfahren hast
du so große wieder kommt und dass sie
mit der eigenen lande besser
begleiten oldfield und china faktisch
sind besitzer von zwei richtige outback
bürger herr die show war
du bist der sohn kleid
schön dich kennenzulernen ich bin sven
väths gut danke und wie ist das leben
auf der kleinen farm kann mich nicht
beklagen
das ist mein vater schön freut mich wie
geht's gut
und wie sieht's aus trocken und heiß es
ist heiß und es ist trocken das stimmt
und viel arbeit
allerdings wir müssen die wasserlöcher
für steve und die zäune müssen repariert
werden
klingt es so habt ihr also arbeit für
mich keine sorge wir finden schon was
für dich
der nächste schock
der südküste in server für inter perfekt
war
in der millionenstadt melden graphen
exzentrische künstler für die ist glück
es zerbrach les gehört
und ich wage mich ein nächstes folgt
wieder auf anfrage und jetzt kriegt ja
bekanntlich nicht am straßenrand
[Musik]
12 1378 km australien mit globetrotter
dem spezialist für massgeschneiderte der
wald mit globetrotter punkt